in the last several videos we learn how
we can approximate an arbitrary function
but a function that is differentiable
and twice and thrice differentiable and
all of the rest how we can approximate a
function around X is equal to zero using
a polynomial if we if we just have a
first-degree polynomial which is just a
constant
you can approximate it with a horizontal
line that just goes through that point
not a great approximation if you have a
first-degree polynomial you can at least
get the slope right at that point if you
get to a second-degree polynomial you
can get something that that hugs the
function a little bit longer if you go
to a third-degree polynomial may be
something that hugs the function even a
little bit longer than that but all of
that was around was focused on
approximating the function around X is
equal to zero and that's why we called
the Maclaurin series or the Taylor
series at X is equal to zero what I want
to do now is expand it a little bit
generalize it a little bit and focus on
the Taylor expansion at x equals
anything so let's say we want to
approximate this function when X so this
is our x axis when X is equal to C so we
can do the exact same thing we could say
look our first approximation is that F
of is that our polynomial our polynomial
at C should be equal to or actually even
let me better our polynomial could just
be at least if it's just going to be a
constant if it's going to be constant it
should at least equal the function
whatever the function equals at C so it
should just equal f of C F of C is a
constant it's that value right over
there we're assuming that C is given and
then you would have this would just be a
horizontal line that goes through F of C
that's P of X is equal to F of C not a
great approximation but then we can try
to go for this having this constraint
matched plus having the derivative
matched so what this constraint gave us
just as a reminder this gave us the fact
that at least P of C the approximation
at C our polynomial at C at least is
going to be equal to F of C right
if you put C over here it doesn't change
what's on the right-hand side because
this is just going to be a constant now
let's get the constraint one more step
what if we want a situation where what
if we want a situation where this is
true and and we want the derivative of
our polynomial to be the same thing as
the derivative of our function when
either of them are at C so for this
situation what if we set up our
polynomial and you'll see a complete
parallel to what we did in earlier
videos we're just going to shift it a
little bit for the fact that we're not
at zero so now let's define P of X to be
equal to F of C F of C plus F prime of C
plus F prime of C so whatever the slope
is at this point of the function
whatever the function slope is x times
you see something slightly different
over here X minus C now let's think
about why we put this what this minus C
is doing what this minus C is doing so
let's test first of all that we didn't
mess up our previous constraint so let's
evaluate this at C so now we know that P
of C and I'm using this exact example so
P of C let me just in a new color
let me try it out so P that's not a new
color P of C P of C is going to be equal
to F of C plus F prime of C times C
minus C wherever you see an X you put a
C in there C minus C well this term
right over here is going to be 0 and so
this whole term right over here is going
to be 0 and so you're just left with
you're just left with P of C is equal to
F of C you're just left with that
constraint right over there and the only
reason why we were able to blank out
this last the second term right over
here is because it we had F prime of C
times X minus C the X minus C makes all
of the terms after this irrelevant we
can go now verify that this is now true
so let's try so P prime of C
P or I should say P prime of X P prime
of X is going to be the derivative of
this which is just zero because this is
going to be a constant plus the
derivative of this right over here and
what's that going to be well that's
going to be you can expand this out to
be F prime of C times X minus F prime of
C times C which would just be constant
so if you take the derivative of this
thing right here you're just going to be
left with an F prime F prime of C so the
derivative of our polynomial is now
constant so obviously obviously if you
were to evaluate this at C P Prime at C
you're going to get F prime of C so once
again it meets it meets the second
constraint and now when you have both of
these terms maybe our approximation will
look something like this it'll at least
have the right slope it'll at least have
the right slope as f of X our
approximation is getting a little bit
better and if we keep doing this and
we're using the exact same logic that we
used when we did it around zero when we
did the Maclaurin expansion you get the
the Taylor expansion the general Taylor
expansion for the for the approximation
of f of X around C to be the polynomial
so the polynomial P of X is going to be
equal to and I'll just expand it out and
this is very similar to what we saw
before F of C plus F prime of C times X
minus C you might even guess what the
next few terms are going to be it's the
exact same logic watch the videos of
Maclaurin series where I go a few more
terms into it it becomes a little bit
more complicated taking the second and
third derivatives and all of the rest
just because you have you have to kind
of expand out these binomials it's the
exact same logic so then you have plus
your second degree term your second
degree F prime prime of C divided by two
factorial and this just like what we saw
the Maclaurin expansion and just to be
clear there's you couldn't say that
there's a 1 factorial down here I didn't
take the trouble to write it because it
doesn't change the value and then that
times X minus C squared plus the third
derivative of the function evaluated
at sea over three factorial times X
minus C to the third power and I think
you get the general idea you can keep
adding more and more and more terms like
this
unfortunately it makes it a little bit
harder you specially if you if you have
you know if you're willing to do the
work it's not so bad but this adding
this X instead of having just X here
instead of just having an x squared here
having an X minus C squared and having
an X minus C to the third
this makes the analytical math a little
bit hairier a little bit more difficult
but this will approximate your function
better as you add more and more terms
around an arbitrary value as opposed to
just around X is equal to 0 and I'll
show you that using Wolfram Alpha in the
next video